this is how it sounded as Case Keenum
finds Stefon Diggs the voice is Paul
Allen of kan in Minneapolis 10 seconds
to go 24:23 Saints Vikings at their own
39 it's third down three receivers right
field on the left Marchand Lattimore 12
yards from Adam case on a deep drop
steps up in the pocket he'll fire to the
right side
[Applause]
when it's your year it's your year
that's all I gotta say
[Applause]
Alan kan longtime voice for the Vikings
been calling games for 16 years now just
like it was scripted ball right calm
under fire DP my best of the week was
that oh man worst of the week was when
we led 17-0 had a missed field goal in
front of half time came out of halftime
with the ball shooed the clock keenum
look very good then things started to go
pear-shaped
here come the Saints with the Hall of
Famer to be a quarterback and they took
the lead that was the worst of the
weekend but the best was was the
Minneapolis miracle set this up for
people to understand from a play-by-play
point of view because you're very
businesslike to start I almost resigned
it feels like you're resigned to the
fact that we got 10 seconds left and I
don't know maybe we get a field goal
last second but it feels like we're
going to lose and we should have won
this game and here we go
with Molina postseason heartache what
were you thinking - yeah from my
standpoint I mean I've done it 16 years
we've had some big moments like o3 and
Sun Devil Stadium 2009 NFC title game
2015 Blair Walsh misses a 27 yard kick
and for me I mean I script scene setters
early in the game but uh no script Damon
I'm thinking where do we need to get to
give ty four-bath a fair chance to walk
off a winner and his career long was
with the New Orleans Saints in 2012
that's Houston 57 yards
so I'm fixated on getting to the 40 with
an opportunity to give him at least a
57-yard try and you know then when that
transpires and you got the rookie safety
Marcus Williams who had a fantastic year
with four picks you know he does what he
does and he runs into his teammate Ken
Crawley and you know the play from what
I understand - Diggs was designed for
to catch it and go out of bounds but
when when he looked ahead Dan and there
was no there there was nobody in front
of him and he just galloped into the
endzone and we won I mean it's
unbelievable and you know radio 101 man
you're the best in the business you know
that there are certain situations that
pop up for which you just cannot plan
and that was one of them the
expectations starting this game were
wrong the expectations starting the
Eagles game I know this game against new
ones like what did you how did you think
this was going to play out I thought the
Vikings absolutely would win I was
flabbergasted when the best defense in
the NFL giving up 12 points a game at
home what was being shredded by Breeze
in the offense and that's with a lot of
respect for New Orleans one of the great
offenses in the last decade of football
for sure I mean so Cox you're there on a
third and one they do a double pass with
Willie Snead Alvin Kamara who blew by
our guys like they were tied to posts
and it was inches from working I mean
the the fortitude to try that player you
kidding me and it almost worked so this
is a very high end offensive operation
the Vikings defense is equally high-end
and the expectation into the game was
that the Vikings were gonna grind out a
victory predicated on defense funny
along the way they wanted on offense but
when the Saints took the lead III text
the Dan ants when the Saints weren't
even leading yet and I said how is New
Orleans still in this game and then all
of a sudden they take the lead what was
that feeling like in the building well
the the the emotional twist of the game
I mean outside of like New England
against Tennessee is so infrequently do
teams dominate from the first second all
the way to the end of the game
specifically in the divisional round of
the playoffs so I mean we're taking the
bleep out of them up 17-0 the Vikings
third down defense is 25% that that's
historically maybe the best in the
history of the NFL and Brees had a zero
passer rating at the end of the first
quarter that's true Brees so it was
working exactly the way I thought it was
going to work or I hoped it would work
and then here they come like that that
well-oiled offensive machine Sean Payton
runs and and we were taking haymakers
and then what's hits the kick the most
underrated play of the game
and was before will let's hit that
43-yarder to give them the lead it's
third and one they run chimera up the
middle and Brian Robinson and backup
safety Anthony Harris stopped him if
they hit that first down the game's over
because Lutz isn't gonna miss and we're
never gonna get the ball back he's Paul
Allen Lee longtime voice for the
Minnesota Vikings on KF a n in
Minneapolis 16 years he's been calling
and joining us in the Dan Patrick show
now you go into Philadelphia it's you
got it at what point do you think my
examiner says alright now let's leave
this behind we got to think about
Philadelphia is he and let them enjoy
today or is it it ended last night I
think that's the atopic end of the week
and you know they're gonna get together
they're starting to get together now
they'll rewatch the game Mike we'll have
this press conference at 2 o'clock
central and then the cliched NFL 24-hour
rule is in play I mean seriously you you
can't believe what we experienced at the
end of the Saints game is is the end of
the road I mean there may not be a level
of excitement experienced until you
hoist the Lombardi greater than what
Stefon Diggs pulled off yesterday but
there there is a bigger prize and the
Super Bowl being in Minneapolis now you
got to go to Philadelphia the crowds
going to be against you the Vikings have
the crowd on their side yesterday and
you know I look back to when the Titans
pulled off the Music City miracle and
Flacco and I think Jacoby Jones got over
the top on the Broncos in the playoffs
you know those teams not only came back
off that emotion to win the next week
they both went to the Super Bowl so that
that's not a guarantee the 2017 Vikings
get to the Superbowl but you can come
back for moments like this
Case Keenum looked like Jim Valvano when
he won the national championship when
he's just looking for somebody to hug
what does he meant to this team
he was a godsend I mean seriously when I
saw case in the offseason I thought it
was nondescript he was in the training
camp battle just to win the backup job
Bradford becomes the NFC Offensive
Player of the Week against New Orleans
then he's gone and case came in and
saved the season and in my 16 years of
calling Vikings football the way
quarterbacks coach Kevin Stefanski and
offensive coordinator Pat Shermer helped
case navigate the entire season
and stay within himself and stay within
his proverbial lane and do it the right
way it's been a masterpiece and he had
an interception yesterday where he got a
little out of body and he threw two at
FedEx Field that put Washington back in
the game and he was chastised for that
but the head coach Mike Zimmer middle of
the season and he learned from it and
he's better for it and his past two digs
was perfect and we walked off winners is
Mike Mike Zimmer allowed to smile I mean
he's a grouchy going individual as it is
you know Mike's not going to be the
guide today at the facility walking
around hugging people I know he's
extremely prideful in this football team
you know when we went to the NFC title
game in 2009 with Brad Childress the
identity of the team was Brett Favre and
yet Adrian Peterson Percy Harvin Sidney
Rice Jared Allen Antoine Winfield yet
some big personalities on that team this
is not that kind of a team that this is
a team with boyish charm this is a very
young team constructed in impeccable
fashion by the general manager Rick
Spielman and it complements each other
in a way I've never seen a Vikings team
in my decade and a half working with
this game Paul it was a lot of fun
listening and good luck against the
Eagles and we'll see you in Minneapolis
thanks for the run have a good day all
right Paul Allen KF a in 16 years
calling Viking games for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]